>>> NOW TO AN IMPORTANT CNN
EXCLUSIVE.
THE UNITED STATES FINALIZING
PLANS TO SENTHE PATRIO
MISSILE DEFENSE SYSTEM TO
UKRAINE AS EARLY AS THIS WEEK
ACCORDING TO SEVERAL U.S.
OFFICIALS.
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS HAVE BEEN
ASKING FOR THE SYSTEM FOR
MONTHS.
LET'S GET TO THE PENTAGON.
BARBARA STARR JOINS US.
TELL US MORE.
>> Reporter: JOHN, RIGHT NOW
DEFENSE SECRETARY LLOYD AUSTIN
HAS TO SIGN OFF ON THE PLAN.
IT GOES TO THE WHITE HOUSE FOR
THE PRESIDENT'S SIGNATURE.
AND THEN ONCE ALL OF THAT IS
DONE AND APPROVED, IT COULD
START MOVING VERY QUICKLY.
WE'RE TOLD THE ANNOUNCEMENT
COULD COME BY THE END OF THE
WEEK.
WHY IS THIS SO IMPORTANT?
WELL, THE PATRIOT IS REALLY THE
PREMIER LONG-RANGE HIGH-ALTITUDE
AIR DEFENSE SYSTEM THAT THE
UKRAINIANS HAVE WANTED FOR
MONTHS AND THE U.S. HAS, SHALL
WE SAY BEEN RESISTING SENDING.
NOW IN THE FACE OF ALL THE
DESTRUCTION WE'RE SEEING IN
UKRAINE WITH THE RUSSIAN MISSILE
ATTACKS, IT LOOKS LIKE THE WHITE
HOUSE IS CHANGING ITS MIND AND
MOVING AHEAD.
SO WHY IS THIS SYSTEM SO
IMPORTANT?
YOU SEE THE PICTURE OF THE
LAUNCHERS THERE.
WHAT THE PATRIOT DOES IS ITS
RADAR LOCKED ON TO AN INCOMING
RUSSIAN MISSILE, LAUNCHING ITS
OWN MISSILE TO SHOOT DOWN THE
RUSSIAN ATTACK AND IT CAN DO IT
AS HIGH ALTITUDE AND LONG RANGE
AND THAT MEANS IF THIS ALL
WORKS, THE UKRAINIAN FORCES CAN
BRING DOWN THOSE RUSSIAN
MISSILES BEFORE THEY GET CLOSE
TO POPULATIONS CENTERS, TO POWER
PLANTS, TO WATER GENERATION
PLANTS, TO BRIDGES, NO
INFRASTRUCTURE.
ALL THE THINGS THAT ARE CAUSING
SUCH DEVASTATION ACROSS UKRAINE.
THIS IS WHAT THE UKRAINIAN
FORCES HAVE BEEN ASKING FOR.
WHAT WILL HAVE TO HAPPEN, ONCE
THIS IS ALL FINALIZED IS UKRAINE
FORCES WILL HAVE TO BE TRAINED.
THEY ARE LIKELY TO GO TO THE
FACILITY, THE U.S. ARMY RUNS IN
GERMANY AND GET THE TRAINING,
MOVE BACK INTO UKRAINE AND
SETTLE THIS UP.
THE BIG QUESTION, OF COURSE,
WHAT WILL VLADIMIR PUTIN HAVE TO
SAY ABOUT ALL OF THIS, JOHN?
>> WILL NOT BE HAPPY WITH THIS
ONE.
BARBARA, GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
SHARING.
AID AS RUSSIAN STRIKES CONTINUE
POUNDING KYIV ENERGY TARGETS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AMID
SUB-ZERO TEMPERATURES.
VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY IS ASKING
FOR MORE THAN 800 AND $40
MILLION THROUGH DOZENS OF
ALLIED NATIONS INSTITUTIONS
HERE AT A CONFERENCE IN PARIS
FOCUSING ON THE NEEDS OF
UKRAINIAN CIVILIANS.
IT COMES AS FIGHTING RAGES
ACROSS THE FRONT LINES AND
HEAVY SHELLING WAS REPORTED
OVERNIGHT IN THE SOUTHERN
REGION AND A KEY TRANSPORT
BRIDGE WAS FOUND IN RUSSIAN
OCCUPIED MULTIPLE.
CNN'S WILL RIPLEY JOINS US LIVE
IN KYIV.
SO IT IS REALLY TOUGH
CONDITIONS TO BE FIGHTING AND,
TOUGH CONDITIONS TO BE LIVING
ON.
>> IT'S CERTAINLY TOUGH
COMMISSIONS TO BE LIVING AND IF
YOU DON'T HAVE POWER, WHICH IS
THE SITUATION FOR MILLIONS OF
UKRAINIANS EVERY TIME THERE'S A
RUSSIAN AIRSTRIKE.
IN FACT, THE ARRANGE SILENCE
JUST WENT OFF IN KYIV A SHORT
TIME AGO ALTHOUGH IT SEEMS AS
IF THEY'RE, NOW THINGS ARE
CLEAR.
IT MIGHT'VE BEEN THE PRESENCE
OF RUSSIAN FIGHTERS DETECTED IN
THE AIR IN UKRAINE.
SOMETIMES THEY SOUND THESE
ALARMS PREEMPTIVELY NATIONWIDE.
THAT IS THE REALITY OF DAILY
LIFE.
IN CERTAIN AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN
THE TARGET OF CONSTANT
BOMBARDMENT, AND ALSO AREAS
THAT ARE BEING HIT HARD WITH
SHELLING ON THE FRONTLINES IN
THE SOUTH, IN THE EAST, IT
TRULY IS INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT
FOR REGULAR PEOPLE TO HOLD ON
TO ANY SEMBLANCE OF NORMALITY
TERMS OF LIVING FOR DAYS ON AND
IN SOME CASES WITHOUT
ELECTRICITY.
EVEN AS CREWS RACED TO RESTORE
THE ENERGY GRID.
SO FOR THE VAST MAJORITY OF
UKRAINIANS, IT IS NOT
NECESSARILY BOMBS RIGHT NOW,
BUT THE LACK OF POWER, AND IN
SOME CASES, INTERRUPTIONS TO
THE WATER SERVICE.
PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE HEAT
DURING THESE OUTAGES ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE,
ESPECIALLY THE ELDERLY IN THOSE
WITH YOUNG CHILDREN.
BUT PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO DO THE
BEST THEY CAN.
THERE HAS BEEN INTENSE FIGHTING,
AND SOME REAL COUNTEROFFENSIVES
HAPPENING FROM THE UKRAINIAN
SIDE.
CERTAINLY ON THE SOUTHERN FRONT
LINE FROM THE LIBERATED CITY OF
KHERSON.
UKRAINIAN FORCES ARE CONTINUING
THEIR ONSLAUGHT ON RUSSIAN HELD
TERRITORIES ACROSS THE DNIPRO
RIVER.
AND IT IS A SITUATION WHERE
THERE ARE REPORTS COMING IN,
AND THEY ARE DIFFICULT TO
CONFIRM WITHOUT BEING ON THE
GROUND, BUT THESE ARE OFFICIALS
THAT ARE EITHER SHARING ON
SOCIAL MEDIA SOURCES, OR
SPEAKING ON VARIOUS PLATFORMS
ARE SPEAKING DIRECTLY TO CNN,
THAT RUSSIAN TARGETS ARE BEING
HIT, AND THERE MAY BE A
SITUATION WITH RUSSIAN FORCES,
NOW THAT UKRAINIAN TALIBAN
SEEMS TO KNOW WHERE THEY'RE
BEING HELD, THEY'RE HAVING TO
SCRAMBLE AND TRY TO FIND NEW
PLACES TO HOUSE THEIR SOLDIERS.
THAT WILL CERTAINLY NOT ONLY
JUST BE THE SITUATION THE SOUTH,
AND MELITOPOL, ONE OF THE
CITIES THAT HAS BEEN HAMMERED
BY UKRAINIAN ARTILLERY, BUT
ALSO A SITUATION HAPPENING IN
THE EAST.
RUSSIAN OCCUPIED LUHANSK REGION,
THE CITY OF CUDI FCA WAS HIT
WITH A STRIKE THAT WAS
REPORTEDLY INCREDIBLY DEADLY,
TALKING ABOUT HUGE LOSSES ON
THE RUSSIAN SIDE, WHEN
UKRAINIAN MISSILES HIT A HOTEL.
AND THE HOTEL WAS REPORTEDLY
HEADQUARTERS FOR THOSE PRIVATE
MERCENARIES OF THE WAGNER GROUP
OUT OF RUSSIA.
THESE ARE THE CIVILIAN FIGHTERS
WHO ESSENTIALLY ARE HIRED TO DO
THE DIRTY WORK THAT THE RUSSIAN
ARMY DOESN'T WANT TO BE
OFFICIALLY CONNECTED TO.
THEY'VE BEEN LINKED TO ALLEGED
HUMAN RIGHTS A TRASH OF THESE
CONFLICTS AROUND THE WORLD.
AND THAT IS POSSIBLE THAT
MEMBERS OF THE WAGNER GROUP,
WHO WERE SLEEPING IN THE HOTEL,
WERE CASUALTY BACKED.
AND SO THE UKRAINIAN MILITARY
CONTINUES TO CALL FOR MORE
WEAPONS, THE CALL FOR PATRIOT
MISSILE DEFENSE AND STORMS AS
THE NUMBER ONE LATTIMORE LIST,
AS A DEFENSE MINISTER TOLD US.
OVER THE WEEKEND WE SPOKE TO
HIM DOWN IN ODESSA.
AND THAT SOUTHERN CITY HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY HIT BY POWER
OUTAGES, EVEN THOUGH THE WAR
HAS NOT COME TO THEIR CITY.
THE IMPACT OF THE WAR IN TERMS
OF THE LOSS OF ELECTRICITY HAS
BEEN A HUGE FACTOR IN THE LIVES
OF PRETTY MUCH ANYONE WHO LIVES
IN THE ODESSA REGION.
>> WILL RIPLEY IN KYIV, THANK
YOU.